Your Twitter handle is @evilhag.
Speaking of witchy presence.
Your twitter is @evilhag.
Why @evilhag?
Because I like it.
I don't know, because why, sorry.
Why do I feel like you're my daughter, and I...
(audience laughter)
And I'm like we gotta talk about this report card.
Whatever.
I like it.
You listen and sit up straight, young lady,
and tell me why you're @evilhag.
No, Daddy, no.
Um, I'm @evilhag because I think/thought hags were--
I've had @evilhag for a long time.
It was like my personal account.
I used to have a blog a long time ago called
SaltySeaHags.blogspot.com where I would write like humor,
jokes, and stuff from the point of view
of a sea witch living in a cave.
And so I thought that was funny, and then I don't know why.
And you were doing that when you were
working NBC as a page, weren't you?
I was, I was doing that when I was, I wasn't a page
at that point, but I was working at NBC
and I got in trouble for it because they were sweeping
the computers every night and they found my hag blog
and they were like we've seen too much and...
(audience laughter)
You have to stop doing this, and so I stopped the blog
but I continued it with the Twitter.
Okay, all right.